Mà Scava ngày mấy sau thủ mì một cho biết, lượng ngà đã tiền sông tại khu vực giá phù hizia, đúng năm của quay nà,
chếm thêm 2,000 gưu cho phía dịch nhằm dành thoảng bộ vùng đất này.
Ngà nói bước tiền tạo thế ui hết, tị trả nú lia phó lê trong khi cấp lúc gần của sự ngà nhìn địch,
trên dịch giúp, kẹt sát, ory khí, kẹp chưa bình luật, sòng chỉ vì có được ua quay nà từ trước,
thở nhận giá tránh ác liệt tại mà chẳng gia phù hizia và lượng quay nà đã phải giúp coi một số lăng,
gió thiệu như lực và hó lực. Trong bước cạnh mắt, mạo gạo đặt, tiền bộ trên trên trường,
và tăng cường tình công bằng mấy bài không người lấy và tên lừa.
Tổng thống của lối miê d'é lệski ngày mì mấy tổng emu đã từ pari để tiêm kiếm các thoảng thật giải hàng về năng lực phòng không và phù hôn quân.
Ông cho biết, một thoảng thật lịch sử về pháp sắp được khoảng tất,
bà gồm tăng cường không quân phòng không và những khả năng phòng bệ khác.
Tổng thống pháp ema đêm bà cồm chức, càng kết quân cấp thêm tiêm kiếm kích mirage và tên lợi ís thơ bà mưa cho cắt,
tổ hợp 70, mạc kiep, đằng bệnh hàng theo hành 1 tiên á vio.
Truyền thăm có thể đêm là toàn chế lực, mời năm, mời đường để hụi quay nà nhạc tiêm kích ra phal y cũng tên lợi và phí tài trong mấy mấy không người lấy.
Pari trời nhiều loch cơ chế tài truyến, nhưng nhìn mạnh, mục tiêu là giúp hụi quay nà ruy trì nở lực ra đe ngà trong giải hà.